[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 6 mai bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez dans cette nouvelle
édition spéciale sur tv 78
coup d'oeil d'abord à la carte du
déconfinement qui sera figé ce jeudi
soir avec les derniers départements en
orange qui passeront soient ouverts soit
au rouge comme c'est le cas pour les
yvelines et le reste de l'ile-de-france
le département où la circulation du cosy
19 reste active
tout comme la tension hospitalière
encore forte sur le territoire avec 735
patients encore hospitalisés dans les
yvelines au chiffre arrêté hier soir
mardi pendant ce néanmoins à la baisse
comme pour les réanimations et puis 1517
c'est le nombre de patients guéris dans
le département est revenu à domicile
certains se considèrent comme les grands
oubliés de cette crise sanitaire les
ambulanciers notamment qui ont vu leur
activité chuter et ont dû se réorganiser
exemple à guyancourt avec ce reportage
d'aurélie ronzet de patrick jacques de
dixmude
cela peut sembler paradoxal mais en
pleine crise sanitaire cette société
d'ambulance privée basé à guyancourt a
vu son activité baisser dès le début du
confinement moins de patients notamment
en raison des ehpad fermé par rapport à
l'activité normale
disons que dans la journée il y avait
des creux parce qu'en fait tout ce qui
était au mieux comme les dialyses tout
ça les sorties des petites gens c'est
sans parler du coville qui à part on a
quand même eu un ralentissement fossé
énorme avertissement quand même on peut
dire qu'on a eu plus de coupure dans la
journée que d'habitude l'entreprise
compte une vingtaine de salariés seuls
60 % de l'effectif a été maintenu pour
intervenir six jours sur sept
parmi les missions d'urgence le
transport de personnes suspectées d'être
atteintes du coc vie 19
une mission qui prend beaucoup plus de
temps en raison des précautions
sanitaires
ils partent pour le
pour un mieux surtout pour pour mieux le
samu donc ils leur fournissent le
matériel des kits nécessaires et de bio
ils portent à l'intervention il faut que
ces faits donc on revient encore une
fois à millau pour rebelote donc pour
faire la désinfection des véhicules
jeter tous les lui quitte une
intervention plus compliqué ce qui
n'empêche pas l'entreprise chaque
vendredi de faire le tour des hôpitaux
yvelinois pour rendre hommage aux
soignants le centre ambulancier des
yvelines en deuil et de la disparition
de calais de boulahia cogérant de la
société
il est décédé le 9 avril dernier des
suites du coc vide 19 après 15 jours en
réanimation à l'hôpital raymond-poincaré
de garches dans les hauts-de-seine dans
l'actualité également cet accord pour
l'organisation des transports en ile de
france à partir du 11 mai il a été
trouvé hier au terme de discussions
entre l'état les organisations
patronales et syndicales et les acteurs
du secteur dans la région
un principe permettre la circulation des
usagers tout en minimisant les risques
sanitaires
le télétravail sera favorisé les
horaires de prise de service et aller
pour éviter les heures de pointe
les entreprises doivent définir de
manière homogène des horaires de départ
et d'arrivée sur des tranches précise
pour leurs salariés à l'offre de
transport sera également ajustés pour
éviter les congestionnement et les
déplacements à vélo encouragé avec un
investissement prévu par la région ile
de france
enfin l'état ouvre une plateforme
digitale dédié pour les pme et tpe pour
qu'elle puisse se fournir en masques
afin d'équiper leurs salariés les
communes elles aussi s'organisent pour
la distribution de masques à leurs
habitants à cinq jours du début du
déconfinement à plaisir les enfants ne
sont pas oubliés la ville a fait appel à
des bénévoles pour confectionner des
protections en tissu spécialement adapté
pour les plus jeunes patrick jacques de
dixmude et au rayon 200 bénévoles ont
répondu présents pour mettre leurs
talents de couturiers aux couturières au
service des enfants plaisir aux as
il y a deux semaines la ville a lancé un
appel pour un défi solidaire équiper les
3500 élèves de masque en tissu
réutilisables à l'origine
roger en fait on ne savait pas si les
écoles
à la reprise des écoles c'est les
masques elle a été obligatoire ou pas
pour les enfants
donc on a lancé ce projet en se disant
est ce qu'on avait des personnes qui
pouvaient nous aider à créer ces masques
enfants puisque dans le commerce était
très compliquée voire impossible de les
avoir donc nos bénévoles nous ont dit
oui pas de problème par contre on n'a
pas de matières premières typiquement
l'élastique était introuvable
un fournisseur a été trouvé pour les
élastiques pour le tissu nécessaires à
la confection des masques et la ville a
fait appel à une entreprise plaisir oise
500 kits ont ainsi pu être distribués
aux bénévoles
je fais 30 masques ce qui était déjà pas
mal jonathan récents comme certaine que
j'ai en effet en plus avec mes
fournitures à moi pour mes voisins mes
petites mamies du quartier et ainsi de
suite
paulo non ce n'était pas pas compliqué
avec le point indique jacques demy la
chine au début était pas très voulait
faire grève
donc j'ai négocié et que ça s'est pas
mal passé à l'école primaire les masques
de protection ne seront pas obligatoires
pour les enfants mais ils pourront tout
de même l'utiliser dans leur quotidien
on a eu tellement de bonnes volontés etc
je pense que les parents sont ravis
d'avoir un masque pour leurs enfants
pour aller faire pour aller prendre les
transports en commun pour aller faire
les courses
un masque sera remis à chaque élève dès
qu'il fera sa rentrée
de son côté le collectif protège ton
soignants constituée de médecins
d'entrepreneurs et d'ingénieurs poursuit
sa mission auprès des soignants de
france ire du matériel de protection a
été remis à l'hôpital mignot et à la
maison de retraite saint louis à
versailles en présence du député des
yvelines jean noël barrot
vingt mille masques en tout ont été
distribués dans cinq établissements le
collectif protège qu'on soigne en
récupérant ligne des dons plus de 5
millions à ce jour et se chargent de
commander du matériel aux normes et en
adéquation avec les besoins des hôpitaux
et des départements
le personnel médical peut également
faire ses demandes en ligne via le site
internet qui s'affiche dans ce contexte
de crise sanitaire les entreprises aussi
s'engager de mettre leur expertise et
leur savoir-faire pour la lutte contre
ce coronavirus bonjour nicolas dans le
ris bonjour de la rédaction de tv 78 de
vous parler justement de ce sujet avec
votre invité est effectivement d'un
gorille avec nous
agnès bedot bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
êtes senior vice president responsable
des activités high performance computing
and quantum chez atos donc c'est les
supercalculateurs et l'informatique
quantique d'atos vous travaillez sur le
site des clayes-sous-bois sur ces sujets
là alors comment les technologies
développées par atos participent à la
lutte contre le coc u19 les
supercalculateurs sont au coeur de la
recherche scientifique française et
mondiale
elle est super créateurs que l'on
fournit chez atos ont conçu et développé
par les équipes de r&d des quais sous
bois c'est un travail de fond qui après
18 mois de recherche et développement
aboutissent à la fourniture et et
allahou développement et la mise sur le
marché de supercalculateurs donc on a ce
type de supercalculateur qui sont
installés sur les plus grands centres de
calcul européens et mondiaux alors
qu'ils utilisent ces outils et pour quoi
faire
les grands centres de recherche
académiques les les les centres de
calcul et de simulation numérique des
grandes entreprises dans différents
domaines que ça soit la recherche
pharmaceutique de la recherche
académique et différents domaines de
simulation numérique est typiquement
dans le cadre actuel de la recherche sur
le profit de 19 les grands centres de
recherche nationaux vont mener des
études autour de la simulation numérique
qui a à voir avec différents sujets
typiquement des recherches
épidémiologiques pour le virus était
recherche de nouvelles molécules pour
pouvoir ensuite apporté des vaccins sur
le marché et ce genre de calcul
fondamentaux qui permettent en analyse
chimique et biologique d'apporter des
solutions
vous l'avez dit ce sont des
supercalculateurs développé sur le site
des clayes-sous-bois est-ce que lorsque
les collaborateurs d'atos se développent
ce type d'outil pense à ces sujets là
justement que ça peut servir dans une
crise exceptionnelle comme on l'a dit
aujourd'hui c'est notre adn je dirais de
fournir à des supercalculateurs pour
apporter des solutions aux industriels
et aux organismes de recherche
quand on parle de pandémie bien sûr
c'est un sujet l'enfant même si ce n'est
pas un sujet qui est forcément dans la
tête de tout le monde et qui ne l'était
pas avant la situation qu'on vit 19 je
dirais mais apporter des solutions des
vaccins à la recherche pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique ou pour tout simplement
les hôpitaux de la recherche sur la
génomique etc
ça fait partie de la même manière que la
recherche sur laquelle le climat où ce
genre de deux thématiques les
supercalculateurs sont absolument des
points d'entrée de recherche mieux sur
la simulation numérique et pour apporter
des outils ou pays aux institutions et
aux à la population génial comment les
collaborateurs ont développé ces
supercalculateurs faut préciser que les
supercalculateurs sur des gros
ordinateurs en fait finalement avec des
puissances de calcul assez importante un
tout à fait les calculs les
supercalculateurs c'est tout simplement
la mise en å parallèle de milliers de
calculateurs enfin de pc individuelle et
qui vous constituez ex-prostituée ce
qu'on appelle une ferme de calcul fait
de milliers et de centaines de milliers
de de puissance de calcul additionner
les ans loos a fabriqué en fabrique un
supercalculateur avec une réseau
d'interprétation rapide et au lieu de
faire un traitement sur une machine et
apc et comme chez vous vous faites à un
traitement numérique en parallèle sur
des milliers de pc c'est ce qui vous
permet d'accélérer et de faire du du
parallel computing
un dernier mot avec vous à des bouts
d'os on va le voir sur ces images dans
le site r&d des clés souvent est en
cours de construction ça sera un site
r&d qui réfléchira sur l'informatique
quantique
en quoi cette informatique quantique
déjà vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que
c'est en quoi il permettra peut-être de
trouver plus rapidement plus facilement
un vaccin contre les virus contre les
pandémies et puis faire d'autres choses
de manière plus rapide
l'informatique quantique et les super
que la gale est super calculateur
quantique sans sens vraiment l'avenir
néanmoins on est déjà au coeur du sujet
effectivement avec les équipes des
questions bois et de r&d puisqu'on
travaille d'ores et déjà et nous avons
mis à disposition un simulateur
quantique et l'idée c'est de pouvoir
travailler sur des algorithmes et des
problématiques que l'on ne sait pas
résoudre aujourd'hui avec les
supercalculateurs classique donc
l'objectif c'est de traiter plus
rapidement via des technologies
nouvelles et des algorithmes avec
l'informatique quantique des d'accélérer
la recherche ses dettes
effectivement il idéalement capacité
d'aller plus vite ou même de réduire un
temps vraiment créé cours certaines
recherches qui prennent énormément en
lui
merci hannesbo pour ses explications
merci et merci à vous et nicolas un
autre groupe explique oki est implantée
à montigny le bretonneux est aussi
pleinement engagé dans cette crise
acteurs de l'innovation spécialisée dans
les services d'ingénierie et de
transformation digitale l'entreprise a
lancé plusieurs projets les explications
dans ce sujet de vos nicolas landré
visière tiers portent ou support pour
des écrans de protection en plexiglas
les différentes productions de
l'innovative d'explo depuis le début du
confinement
grâce à son imprimante 3d le site de
montigny le bretonneux a participé à un
réseau d'ateliers de fabrication
objectif répondre aux besoins des
personnes en première ligne dans la
région c'est parti d'un mouvement très
large en france à partir de là en fait
on à 110,9 lab comme on a une imprimante
3d on a voulu participer
on s'est rapprochés de notre direction
en interne auprès des collaborateurs qui
étaient tous qui justement sont restées
en activité pour faire ces éléments
pourrait d autres projets l'utilisation
de l'intelligence artificielle pour
étudier des mutations du colis de 10,9
dans plusieurs pays à partir de données
publiques
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on peut par
exemple associer une souche partie
l'ua avec la mortalité qui est observé
dans les régions où les pays dans
lesquels elle série après le second
enjeu c'est de déterminer si le virus a
suffisamment muté pour qu'un vaccin
universel ne soit pas suffisant a donc
pour le moment c'est pas le cas donc
c'est plutôt rassurant répondre à cette
crise sanitaire synonyme d'innovation
des innovations au niveau technologique
mais aussi dans la manière d'innover une
activité entre les collaborateurs du
groupe ouverte vers d'autres partenaires
extérieurs on a appris que l'on pouvait
dépasser des processus y aller vite sur
les choses qui ont du sens on a appris
que individuellement les collaborateurs
avait plein de ressources plein d'idées
plein de propositions et qu'il pouvait
qu on n'était pas les seul tenant du
savoir et que c'est en échangeant étant
beaucoup plus ouvert que finalement les
bonnes idées arrivent comme beaucoup
d'entreprises explique s'est aussi
adaptée au contexte la majorité des
salariés ont poursuivi leur activité en
télétravail
malgré le contexte de crise sanitaire la
collecte de sang et de plaquettes s'est
poursuivie quel bilan dresses
l'établissement français du sang en
d'ile-de-france et quelles évolutions à
attendre après le déconfinement les
éléments de réponse dans cet entretien
mené par wilfrid richy et stéphane noël
directeur en ile-de-france de
l'établissement français du sang est en
ligne avec nos hobbies ou re bonjour
après plus de cinquante jours de
confinement quel bilan faites-vous de
cette collecte de sang y at il une
poursuite de la mobilisation des
franciliens déjà écouté le bilan que
nous faisons de la collecte pendant suit
50 jours de confinement est un bilan
effectivement intéressant ce sens où les
franciliens se sont fortement mobilisés
à nos côtés nous avons vécu des périodes
assez difficile notamment juste après
l'annnonce du confinement total par le
président de la république où les
français de manière globale se sont
fortement interrogé quant à la
possibilité d'aller donner leur sang et
quelques jours après il ya eu un
formidable élan de générosité qui nous a
permis de faire face aux besoins des
patients puisqu'il faut le rappeler même
pendant cette période de confinement
même pendant cette période si
particulière
les malades continuent à avoir besoin de
produits sanguins il est important de
continuer à donner son sang cette
mobilisation a été très forte
elle a été très très forte pendant les
premiers jours du confinement
effectivement aujourd'hui on voit
qu'avec le temps elle commence un petit
peu à s'émousser
comment ça un petit peu à s'estomper il
est important aujourd'hui de de se
remobiliser à nouveau parce que nous
avons besoin des donneurs dans la durée
nous avons oblique aussi besoin des
personnes qui ne donne pas encore leur
sens et qui pourraient nous rejoindre et
il est important que chaque jour nous
puissions son ensemble de nos points de
collecte que soient nos maisons du don
où que ce soit nos collectes mobiles et
bien de voir les franciliens nous
rejoindre et venir donner leur chance
est extrêmement important comment se
passent les collectes justement
concrètement la prise de rendez vous est
conseillé ou obligatoire alors
aujourd'hui les collectes se déroule en
respectant de manière très scrupuleuse
l'ensemble des mesures pour garantir la
sécurité des donneurs et donc nous
appliquons des mesures très strictes en
matière d'hygiène des mains
nous mettons à disposition de la
solution hydroalcoolique dès l'entrée
sur nos connect nous équipant chaque
donneur d'un masque
nous prenons des mesures pour que les
règles de distanciation soient respectés
aux différents stades de la collecte
nous organisons l'étape de la collation
pour faire en sorte que les donneurs
soient suffisamment distants les uns des
autres pour garantir absolument la
sécurité de tous et oui depuis quelques
semaines nous avons mis en place un
système de rendez vous deux qui est
d'ailleurs très plébiscité par les
donneurs de la mesure où il permet
véritablement d'organiser son don du
sang est aujourd'hui pour venir sur nos
collectes et bien il est nécessaire de
prendre rendez vous et c'est très simple
on va sur notre site internet
on peut trouver tous nos lieux de
collecte
soit fixe ou mobile on clique sur le
lieu de collecte et de la en accès d'un
lien qui nous permet de prendre rendez
vous sur un site internet dédié un seul
un site internet qui s'affiche à l'écran
je leur donne mon en tirer rendez-vous
tirait donc 200 points est fait ce point
sante.fr voilà mais ils s'affichent pour
tous ceux qui voudraient prendre rendez
vous est donné sans et plaquettes avec
le déconfinement qui s'annonce qui
devrait débuter à partir du 11 mai
est-ce que les modalités vont changer et
évoluer pour pouvoir donner est ce que
vous allez revoir encore le processus
alors avec le déconfinement nous restons
extrêmement attentifs puisque vous le
savez la région ile-de-france pour
l'instant est encore classé rouge et de
ce fait les mesures de précaution les
règles de sécurité vont rester un très
haut niveau
donc tout ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure en matière de distanciation
sociale en matière de port du masque en
matière de d'hygiène des mains
ce sont des mesures que nous allons
maintenir et que nous allons maintenir
dans la durée
aussi longtemps qu'il sera nécessaire
pour garantir la sécurité des donneurs
et d'autre part les mesures de prise de
rendez-vous sont aussi des mesures que
nous allons maintenir dans la durée pour
garantir qu'il n'y a pas d'afflux massif
ponctuellement de donneurs et faire en
sorte que les donneurs quand ils
viennent sur les collectes
il reste le temps juste nécessaire à la
réalisation du don de sang ni plus ni
moins et puis ces rendez vous étant
tellement plébiscité aujourd'hui par les
donneurs et bien c'est même une mesure
que nous envisageons de pérenniser au
delà du camp en filmant parce que le
permet à touches de virtuellement
s'organiser et puis une dernière
question sur la mobilisation aussi de la
ffs le fs participent à cette recherce
autour du dico vide peut-être nous en
dire quelques mots ya une mobilisation
aussi
alors effectivement l'établissement
français du sang participent à une
recherche sur un protocole que nous
appelons corrie place mme il s'agit
d'utiliser du plasma que nous prélevons
chez des potes donneurs qui sont des
patients qu'ovide convalescent en
espérant que les anticorps qui ont été
développés par ces patients ne puissent
permettre à des patients aujourd'hui
hospitalisé
2 faire face aux que vit donc ses
travaux sont actuellement en cours
nous sommes très mobilisés en
ile-de-france pour prélever du plasma
chez des patients convalescent de la
mesure où nous sommes l'un des
principaux bassins de deux malades du
code vide et nous espérons obtenir dans
les prochaines semaines les résultats de
cet essai clinique
donc c'est un essai qui est menée de
manière extrêmement rigoureuse et nous
souhaitons attendre les conclusions
définitives de cet essai avant de
communiquer sur les résultats
merci beaucoup stéphane noël directeur
de l'établissement français du sang en
ile-de-france d'avoir été en ligne avec
nos aujourd'hui merci à vous merci
cette information à présent qui n'est
pas lié au contexte de coronavirus et
l'ouverture de cette enquête pour
torture violences aggravées et
violations de libertés individuelles par
le parquet de nanterre elle fait suite à
cette arrestation souvenez vous en
décembre 2010 850 de jeunes avaient été
interpellés à mantes la jolie en marge
des violences lycéenne la scène filmée
par un policier avait suscité un tollé
en france est la procédure fait suite à
une plainte avec constitution de partie
civile déposée contre x en décembre
dernier
et quelque chose de plus léger pour
terminer vous en avez l'habitude depuis
le début de ce confinement votre
rubrique dans les salles devient aide
dans vos canapés une sélection de films
à voir directement depuis et chez vous
aujourd'hui c'est un cinéphile
indépendant d'airtran pigné qui vous
donne sa sélection est bien dans son
canapé puisqu'on est bien
confortablement installés moi je vous
propose nous confiner intelligemment
alors en ou dépendants avec toute la
famille avec un film de circonstance
alexandre le bienheureux de yves robert
alors pour un grand nombre d'entre vous
c'est un film que vous connaissez déjà
c'est un film avec jean yanne et marlène
jobert principalement c'est un film qui
raconte l'histoire d'un homme à la
campagne qui est poussé au travail
harcelé de travail par sa femme qui est
dit la grande une très belle femme jouée
par françoise briand et à jour malheur
cette femme meurt dans un accident de
voiture terrible et alexandre se
retrouve à pouvoir accomplir le destin
qu'ils rêvent d'accomplir depuis
toujours se confiner dans sa chambre et
attendre attendre que le temps passe et
organiser sa vie sans rien faire ce qui
met évidemment la totalité de la société
du village en ébullition alors jean
raconterai pas plus c'est ça le pitch
principal mais c'est un film absolument
délicieux il ya toute une première
partie qui est très dur l'est très très
drôle très comique les enfants adoreront
vous qu'il n'avait jamais vu adultes
adorerait aussi parce que c'est vraiment
très très piquant et puis là toute la
dernière partie c'est vraiment une
réflexion très très belle sur bas
justement sur la société qu'est ce que
c'est qu'avoir un rôle dans la société à
quoi ça sert de faire fonctionner une
société pourquoi on va fonctionner une
société et est ce qu'on a le droit de ne
pas vouloir faire fonctionner cette
société voilà donc c'était alexandre le
bienheureux de yves robert
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de votre fidélité restez chez vous
et très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]